[Music]
rainbows are one of the most beautiful
sights in nature and we hugely see it on
a rainy day but you will be surprised to
know that you can even see it on sunny
days if you're near water faults or
fountains so what is really required for
the rainbow to be formed the two things
that are required for the rainbow to
appear are white light and tiny water
droplets the latter is quite important
for its formation in the rainy season
many water droplets are present in our
atmosphere and hence we mostly see the
rainbow in this season okay so how do
these two combine together to form a
rainbow
well the formation of the rainbow
results from the simplest of optical
phenomena known as refraction and total
internal reflection yes among these two
we know quite a lot about refraction of
light okay so let's see how sunlight and
droplets interact with each other first
of all suppose that we're looking up at
a rainbow from some point on the surface
of the earth we see the colors of a
rainbow in order red orange yellow green
blue indigo and violet from top to
bottom we might not be able to see
indigo that well because our eyes are
not quite sensitive to that color now as
I told you
rainbows during the rainy season are
formed due to the presence of water
droplets in the atmosphere there are
many of these where a rainbow is formed
so if you are only looking at the red
part of the rainbow the simple reason
that we're able to see anything around
us is because the light from that
particular object is traveling to our
eyes similarly the red light from the
upper part of the rainbow is traveling
to our eyes enabling us to see it but
where is this red light coming from in
order to understand this let's consider
a single water droplet from this red
region and suppose the white sunlight is
incident at this point on it the angle
at which the light is incident is very
important and I will tell you why in a
little while it will
some of the light at the boundary and
refract some of it
the reflected light is white light again
and it's going away from our eyes so we
ignore this as this light does not help
in forming rainbows but we know that the
white light of Sun is composed of seven
primary colors its Vibgyor
and we also know that the prism will
break this white light into its
constituent colors when allowed to pass
through it a water droplet behaves
exactly like a prism it disperses the
white sunlight at the entry point what
happens next
this dispersed light falls onto the rare
side of the droplet and each light color
is again refracted by different angles
but wait a moment look at this point why
is the light getting refracted in the
same medium well you must have assumed
that it will pass through the air and
not back through the water this is
happening because of an optical
phenomenon known as total internal
reflection
let me quickly enlighten you about this
we know when the light travels from an
optically denser to an optically rarer
medium it bends away from the normal and
greater the angle of incidence greater
will be the angle of refraction but
here's the interesting part there is
some angle called the critical angle at
which the refracted ray will be
perpendicular to the normal line that's
right
asked this angle of incidence we can see
that the refracted ray is perpendicular
to the normal and if I further increase
the angle of incidence then the
refracted ray will now travel through
the incident medium so if you notice the
Ray is actually reflecting in the same
medium the same thing happens here in a
water droplet as well this angle of
incidence at this surface for each
colored light is such that they all bent
in the same medium so these different
colored rays are now at the air-water
interface again
for the third time this time however the
total internal reflection does not occur
and they Bend in air but notice that all
the colors in air are now separated by
quite an
mount the three refractions create the
larger gap between these colors all the
droplets in this red portion of the
rainbow behave in the same way but wait
a moment these droplets are refracting
the light of all colors then why are we
able to see only the red color in this
region of the rainbow this is because
only the red color from this region
reaches our eyes all the other colors
are refracted at such a large angle that
they do not reach our eyes on the ground
same thing happens for the remaining
regions of a rainbow as well for
instance droplets present in the violet
region also send the light back in the
same way but only the violet color
reaches us and the remaining colors are
not visible I hope that you now have a
basic understanding of how a rainbow
forms in the sky we will come up with
more interesting topics in our future
videos so don't forget to tune in
[Music]
you